- [Interviewer] All right, Greg.
Greg, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- South Central, Los Angeles.
- South Central.
- [Greg] Around by Hoover
Street in Vermont, in that area,
back in the 70s.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- No, I just had my...
Really, I had my mother
and my grandmother,
but mostly my grandmother
because my mother, she did...
was doing a lot of time in
jail, and all that stuff,
because she used to steal
and all that, you know,
what they called boosting-
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- back then in the days,
but she was a booster.
So, basically just my grandmother.
- [Interviewer] And where's dad?
- Hmm?
- Where's your dad?
- Really, I couldn't
tell you. I don't know.
He was like...
But last I heard he
was somewhere in Texas,
but he wasn't around then.
And last I seen my dad was
probably about my sixth birthday.
My six year birthday,
that's probably the last time I seen him,
and I aint see him one more, so...
- [Interviewer] And so
how was your childhood?
- It was kinda rough.
It was rough 'cause it..
Basically 'cause I grew up in a house
where it was more women than anything,
more women around, it wasn't
that many male figures
- [Interviewer] No brothers?
- No. Brothers, but he was in....
Well, it's just...
'Cause this is part it's kind of funny
'cause
I have a different father
than my other three brothers.
Now, one of my three
brothers grew up with me,
the other two was staying
like with their father
like in Compton somewhere, right?
So I never even knew them.
I never even met them,
they never came around or anything.
And then the brother that lived with us,
he did most of his time in
Camp YAE and stuff like that.
So I was basically by
myself, really, you know,
without the support of
like brothers and stuff.
I don't have no sisters, you know.
And, yeah, it was kinda rough growing up.
And then that's where all the influence
from the guys in the neighborhood
came in from, you know,
not having that many males around.
So the influence that
I got from male figures
came from the streets, you know,
and guys in the streets
that was doing things,
that names popped in, you know,
and stuff like that, you know, so...
- [Interviewer] So you joined a gang?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Which gang? Hoover?
- Hoover, yeah, yeah.
I was from Hoover and, you know,
and it made me feel like a
part of something, you know,
I was a part of something then.
And I was like...
You see I'm a small guy, so
I was always small, you know.
So a lot of guys used to
test me a lot, you know,
'cause I was small
and so I had to pretty much prove myself.
And once I got...
became a member of a gang, you know,
I really didn't have
that problems that much.
Only problem...
Time I had that problem was
with guys inside the gang,
that's from my gang.
But outside of us,
never had that problem
no more of that, really,
'cause they didn't want mess around.
They didn't want, you know, problems.
- [Interviewer] And
Hoover is a powerful gang
- (laughs) Yeah.
Especially back then in
the '80s, they was bad.
It was bad.
- [Interviewer] What do they call them,
Crip and Blood Killers?
- Well, back then it was
Crips, there wasn't...
This, the new Crips and Blood
Killers things came later on,
in like in the '90s and stuff.
But I'll be 52 in July,
so I was just the Crips,
we was all Crips, you know.
So it wasn't no orange color,
and all this and that,
it was just blue,
we was Crips.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Oh.
So you, at some point, got
into selling drugs, right?
- Yes. And that's from the
time that crack epidemic, like,
first kicked in, like, in around '83, '84.
'83, and...
And, we used to be, me and a
couple of more of my buddies,
we used to hang on 81st,
between Hoover and Vermont, which was...
They just call it the tracks, right?
And that's where all the
drug action was going on,
where guys used to come...
People used to come by drugs and stuff.
And there was this one apartment
building we used to hang at
where most of the customers came.
So it was me and about three or four
of my other homies, right?
And we, at that time,
when it first came...
like crack first...
It wasn't really...
Like, if you didn't use
the pipe, it was cool.
If you just put some on
some weed and smoke it,
which what we used to do, so...
- [Interviewer] Primos.
- Yeah, primos, you know
So we used to rob...
We used to rob the customers.
We would rob some customers
and then we'll go buy us some,
we'll crush it all down
then make some primos,
and smoke and go rob customers, and rob...
You know, we would just
go back like that, right?
Never really was trying to
hurt nobody but we was just...
Just we liked the primos
and this was our neighborhood.
and you're coming over here, you know?
And a couple of guys,
it's guys in his building,
this apartment building,
used to sell dope for somebody
and we didn't know,
we hardly new that name but we
didn't know the dude, right?
Which was Freeway, was Rick,
some of Rick workers was in there.
So they got tired of us robbing
the customers and all that,
so they went and told Rick.
So one night we was all out there
and some guy pulled up,
jumped out of his truck, like,
"Hey, man. Let me holler at y'all man."
And we looking at him like,
"Who the fuck is this dude?"
I mean, can I cuss?
No.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah.
- All right. Like, "Who the
is this dude?" you know?
And he come over,
"Look, man. Y'all don't
got to do that, look."
And he go, he said, "Stay
here and I'll be right back."
So we stayed and somebody is like,
"Man, that was Rick. That was Rick.
That was Rick, right?"
So he comes back.
he comes back with like a
Ziploc baggie full of dope.
So he just started passing it to us.
It's like four or five of us,
and he pass it all out to us.
And he told us that, "Just sell that.
Sell this and come back to me,
and I'll get y'all some more.
And y'all don't have to do all that, man.
Y'all can do what you y'all want to do."
And that's like where it
started, like right there.
So we did it.
Some of us continued
to keep smoking primos,
some of us seen the opportunity
of having this stuff
and getting to some...
making a lot of money, you know?
So, you know, we sold some.
Some of us went around there,
got more, he gave us more,
and this and that, "Look out for us."
And sometimes we didn't
even need to have money.
Like, "Man, I lost my money gambling,"
or, "I did this or did that."
And we used to go around and
he would just give us, like,
"Here," bam, you know,
"Go take care of yourself, man."
And that's how it all, like, all started.
And we went half like...
Like, four of us went
half on a car. (laughs)
We all bought like a old '66 Chevy,
and we all put our money in.
I think we paid probably like 600,
600 or 700 for it.
It was a '66 Chevy, right?
And we take turns driving it
but we wouldn't go outside
of the neighborhood.
Basically we would just ride
between Florence and Manchester,
and Vermont and Figueroa,
that's the only area we
would ride around in, right?
But we loaded, packed...
Car packed with guns and
all this and that and we...
just looking for stuff like that
Before it's the drugs...
the drug game,
and it was getting
really popular right then
and at that time, right?
Now in that apartment building
that I was telling you about,
it was this Jamaican lived
in there, this Jamaican guy,
he used to smoke.
They used to call him King Flee,
he was a Jamaican named King Flee.
And he used to...
He used to cook dope.
And he taught me
I used to always watch him all the time.
So he basically taught
me how to cook dope,
and I was only like 14, 15.
- [Interviewer] Which is making me rock?
- Yeah, yeah. Turning the
powder into rock, right.
So I used to watch him and
I learned how to do it.
And at that time it wasn't
that many people who knew how,
but I learned how to do it real fast.
So now, as far as Hoover's concerned,
you got the differences sections,
the 50s, the 70s, and 80s, like that.
I'm from the 70s
but a lot of guys I used to hang with
they was from Eight-Tray
and I was from Seven-Four.
So a lot of guys didn't know
how to cook, like I said,
and I learned how to cook from Rick.
I mean, not from Rick,
from King Flee, right?
So a lot of guys started
coming to get me to cook dope,
to cook the dope up, right?
So I cook it up for
them and all that stuff.
And it was crazy
because I don't know
how it got back to Rick,
but one day I was cooking
for my homie, Bug,
and he came in the house...
And Bug left and came back with him
and showed him like, "Look."
Like, and I was cooking all...
I was cooking the dope.
I used to use...
In my grand mother's
house, her dish drainer.
I used to have it filled up
with like the baby food bottles,
and I have them all
lined up inside of there.
So he came one day and
he said, "Oh, yeah."
And he seen what I was doing,
he seen that I kinda
knew what I was doing,
and he's asking me,
"How did you just learn how to
do this, and this and that?"
And I just told him and shit.
And he was like,
"Well, I got some stuff I
need you you to help me out."
So one day he came and got me, man.
I mean, I probably was
cooking dope for like...
It seemed like two days all day,
all day just cooking, cooking,
cooking, and smoking primos.
And he didn't really care, I'd just smoke
That's why I stay up.
I stayed up...
I stay woke for weeks, weeks,
not just constantly,
but I might stay up for a couple of days
and sleep for a few hours
and back up, you know?
And I was young,
I guess I had a lot of energy
or whatever, you know, really.
Yeah, and then he used to give us...
give us shows
and gives all kinds of like car shows,
rap concerts, and all this
different type of stuff.
And he used to really look
out for our neighborhood.
That's why a lot of people say
Ricky dealt with the
Hoovers more than anything,
he has a lot of spots
in our hood, you know,
and we used to look out for him,
and he looked out for us, you know?
And it started, you know, like that.
But I guess they had a little
clique called Freeways,
Freeway Boys.
So I guess I was one of them, you know.
It was a lot of guys,
they were Freeway Boys.
So we really didn't have
a lot to worry about.
But the only thing with me,
I was still caught up
between the money, okay,
either make the money and gang banging,
and I was, like, straddled.
I was straddling the fence a lot.
I straddled the fence, you know.
Sometime I'd go hang out
with the Freeway Boys,
we hanged out with that clique,
but then sometime I'll be with my homies.
See, all of the Hoovers
ain't Freeway Boys,
some of them is,
because them was just the ones
that was more into the money
than the gang banging.
Me, I was straddled.
I didn't know what side I wanted to go on
because my homies they
brought me out of this...
I can say they like saved
me from, I don't know,
like when I didn't have nobody
and like that they'd call,
but then we were still broke.
I was broke,
and then that's when Freeway come through
and now he saved me from
being broke, and I had money.
I was young, 14, 15, 16.
I had two cars, it was buckets though.
They was shitty but it...
To be 16 with two cars, that was nice.
I ain't had no license or nothing, right?
And, yeah, I had a little money put up,
a little saved up for my age.
And back then it was...
I was doing pretty good, you know.
- [Interviewer] And where
did it go from there?
Did it escalate or...
'Cause he was making a lot of money
- He was making a lot of money
and we was making money too.
But, see, back then, I didn't...
We didn't...
I didn't know about the save.
Save, I didn't know nothing about savings.
Like, get it, spend it, get it, spend it.
So I had a bunch of stuff...
I had a bunch of stuff, but, see,
I didn't have a lot, a lot of money,
a lot, a lot of money.
You know,
I had some thousands, a few thousands,
and then once my grandmother...
Once my grandmother figured...
Well, once she got wind
of what was going on
and everything like that,
and then now, she said...
It started 'cause I
wasn't going to school.
I stopped going to school.
First I used to at least go to school
and then I just stopped going to school,
I'd go straight to the spot.
- [Interviewer] At what point?
What grade?
- I was around 16, 16.
I just pretty much stopped
going to school, you know.
So she say, "Okay, well,
if you're going to do this,
do it right."
And then she started telling
me how to manage my money,
what I should do with the money.
And, because at that point,
I guess she just came,
came to terms that she
couldn't do nothing about it,
you know, she couldn't stop me.
So I would...
She would manage some of my money,
put some of money up for me and stuff.
And even when I was short,
she would loan me money.
She would give me money to...
Like I'm short like 500
to get (indistinct),
and she would give it to me.
She would give it to me, you know,
"Just give me my money
back," and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] So where
you're dealing as well.
- Yeah. Yeah, we had to.
We used to take shifts
working in the spot, right?
We had a spot on 79th,
on 79th between Hoover and Vermont,
which was the main spot.
And so we'd take shifts.
Like, and mine was in the morning,
that's the reason I
stopped going to school
because my shift ended
up being in the morning,
so I couldn't go to school
and I had to work the spot.
So, yeah, we was dealing in the spot.
- [Interviewer] How much money
were people making back then?
- (sights) A lot.
A lot because...
And that you didn't get as much,
the dope wasn't like it is now.
Like now, the dope is really garbage,
it's all garbage.
Back then, you didn't get as much.
If you spent $25,
you'd probably get for what
they give up for $5 now,
that's probably what you
would've got for $25 back then,
you know,
and that it wasn't no fight out of rocks,
and nickles and dimes,
all that type of stuff.
It was 25, 50, you know,
and stuff like that.
Quarter pieces, half
ounces, and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] But it was more pure.
- It was more pure.
The dope was better.
and it was good dope.
And so right now, they give you a...
You might get a gram for $5
out here because it's garbage,
it's nothing.
And they ain't not making
no money like that.
You not making no money.
These people, they ain't making money.
Like they say,
"If you didn't get rich in
the 80's off of selling drugs,
you're not going to do it now,
you're not going to do it now."
That was the time to really get rich.
Yeah, like I said, I could...
I tell people always, I say,
"I should be rich right now.
I supposed to be a millionaire right now
because I was there at the beginning."
- [Interviewer] You were
there in the heyday.
- Yeah, I think in the heyday,
because they had all...
Back then they had all these
different cliques they had.
Okay, they had Freeway Boys,
they had Whitey's Enterprise,
they had Third World,
these is all little drug
cliques in the LA area.
- [Interviewer] But Freeway Rick
was kind of running the whole..
- [Greg] He was the man.
He was the main man.
- [Interviewer] What kind of money
do you think he was making?
- [Greg] (sighs) Then I
didn't know he was making
as much money as he was making.
But now,
I know for a fact that
he was making millions,
he was making millions.
He had companies and stuff.
Back then when a lot of guys that's....
like selling didn't have
businesses, they'd just get...
They had mattress money,
sticking money under
the mattress type stuff.
But this man had...
was owning.
He was smart, man.
That dude was smart.
He was a smart...
One of the, probably, smartest
people I ever met, right?
And
because
he
took his money and bought businesses.
He bought stuff,
and he bought stuff that
would make more money
like legally, you know?
And he was just funding it.
It's like it was being
funded, at the beginning,
with the drug money,
then after that, it took care of itself.
- [Interviewer] And then
where did he go from there?
- [Greg] To jail. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] And Where is he today?
- [Greg] Right now, he's out.
He's doing some stuff.
He's doing, like, got record company
and stuff like that, you know.
And I ain't talked to him in a long time
since he first got out,
but he has like record companies
and little rap....
a little rap stuff,
'cause that's what's making
money right now, you know,
so he's trying to get into that.
He got a couple of artists
and all that stuff.
But back then, back then, man...
And if you see him,
if you would see him, right,
you would never, you would never...
It was like my cousin walk up
and they'd be like, "That's Rick."
You'd be like, "That can't be
rick Rich right there," right?
"Not this guy."
He he wasn't flashy.
He might have a tank top and some jeans,
and driving his tow truck
'cause he had the tow truck company too.
He would be driving one of
his trucks, and that's it.
And you'd be like, "That's him?"
'Cause back then, you see a lot of guys,
you had the flashy guy, like...
- [Interviewer] You had pimps.
- Huh?
- Yeah, you had pimps but
you had the flashy guys.
Like, I'm talking about the drug dealers
that you can tell they was drug dealers
'cause they had the chains
with the big old medallions on it,
the big Turkish ropes and...
He wasn't like that,
he was like a normal...
He was like you.
He would look,
he dress normal like a regular guy.
You would never know.
You would never know
and think he had all that money
or he was the guy who...
- He smart to stay-
- He was smart.
- [Interviewer] Low key
- You know, he kept low profile.
He wouldn't draw a lot
of attention to his self.
And we used to...
Well, I used to wonder,
but we never did question
it or question him,
or even question each other.
But maybe a couple of us talked like,
"Man, where the fuck is he
getting all his dope from?
Where is he getting
all his dope from him."
'Cause he...
That man had-
- [Interviewer] So you were cooking it,
where do you think it was coming from?
- I had no idea about back then
or at the time, I really
didn't care, right,
as long as I was getting
what I needed, you know,
as long he was taking care, so...
He put that up there to blind
and not even question it, you know?
Certain things that'd be put
in your face so it just...
could just blind you from the questions
you should be asking, like,
"Man, where the fuck is this
dude getting his shit from?
He is like us.
Where fuck is he...
Who he working with?"
You know what I mean?
But later on,
when he got arrested and all that stuff.
and then we found out where
a lot of it was coming from.
- [Interviewer] Which was where?
- Was from the CIA.
Yeah, the CIA and stuff like that.
They was...
He was working for them.
They was giving him stuff
and he was working for them.
And like the last time he got caught,
and that was...
He was pretty much forced to do that.
The the last transaction he did,
he was pretty much forced
to do it because he...
I guess when you get caught up with them,
like the mafia or some
shit, you can't get out.
If they tell you,
'cause they got all these things on you,
they can snatch you anytime they want to.
But he did his job for them,
so they just let him be cool,
let him go on about his business,
and go on and finish
doing what you're doing.
But I guess there's
somebody that they wanted,
there's somebody else that they wanted,
but they had to use him to
do it that one last time,
and that's when he
ended up getting caught,
that one last time.
But then everything came to light,
that's why he ended up getting out.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, he was there,
there was some people
and he said they told him,
"We need you to do this one
last one last buy," which was...
I think it was something like 200 keys
or some shit like that.
And he didn't want to do it
but they made him do it, like, you know,
"You're going to do it.
Do it or we gonna do you," all right?
So I guess he did it and
then they got caught,
and he got caught up, you know.
- [Interviewer] Do you miss those days?
- Yeah I do. I do.
It's way better.
I miss it for the simple fact,
I know what I would do now.
I would do things way different, way...
I would do more things more like him,
the way he was doing it.
Not working for the CIA,
I wouldn't wanna do nothing like that.
Because once you get to that level,
it's dangerous.
- [Interviewer] But the money was flowing
and that made everything kind of-
- The money was flowing and...
and you could...
You could make a lot of money
back then, a lot of money.
And a lot...
Like I said, I should be rich.
I should be a millionaire right now.
51, and I was started when I was like 14,
I would be rich.
And then the person,
the connection that I had... (sighs)
'Cause see, a lot of guys...
So this is where turned around
A lot of the guys that was...
Like, a couple of my homies
that was with me, you know,
the ones in my little crew,
some of those...
some of them just went totally
like stopped doing drugs,
and they started really
making a lot of money.
You know, me, some of us kept doing drugs,
like a couple of us.
We was still sneaking, closet smoking
and stuff like that, you know,
and it ended up taking its toll on us,
and we ended...
See why I ended up down
(laughing) here, you know.
- [Interviewer] You're living on Skid Row.
- Yeah, living on Skid Row,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- you know.
- [Interviewer] What is it
about crack or other the drugs
that just undermines a
person's ability to thrive
and be successful in life, and all.
It seems to, 'cause-
- It's like, I know...
A lot of other drugs,
I can't 'cause
the drug that...
that beat me up the most was crack,
that whipped me the most.
I did PCP but not on that level.
You know, I just smoked a little and...
'Cause I don't really like
that taste of it and all that.
But crack, it's the...
The high makes you feel like
you're on top of the world,
like they say,
like you can accomplish anything.
But when you feeling like that,
and then it goes like...
like that really fast,
and you don't want that feeling,
and that feeling to go away,
'cause now I can't...
I'm discombobulated a little bit.
My thoughts are not straight like they was
when I was high, so I got
to get it back up there,
so you do it more, you do it more.
And that's what it was,
it takes you up,
it brings you down real fast
to where you have to want to try...
You have to do more and more
to try to stay up to that level,
to where your thinking is like...
and that's it.
At the time, your stuff
is just going and going.
Money is just going
because you're trying to
keep your mind at this level.
- [Interviewer] The drug
becomes the first priority.
- Yes
- More than your family,
more than your job, more than your health,
more than anything.
- Yeah, 'cause you really don't...
You think about the stuff but you...
I don't know,
it's like it fools into
thinking like different...
thinking certain things.
I swear, I used to sit up and get high,
and swear up and down
I could figured out how
to get into the bank.
"I know how to get in
this bank and do stuff,"
and that's this type of
stuff it makes you think.
Like, makes you think you is really smart,
like you really...
Everything, you're thinking
like you're super smart,
and which you're not, you're not.
You're really pretty stupid, you know,
to let this little...
As my grandmother told me once I started
getting really bad on the drugs, she said,
"I always thought you
were stronger than that.
How could you let this little rock...
Like, what? You're a hundred
and something pounds,
this thing probably weighs at...
How is you letting this control
you like that?
You gotta be stupid."
And again, and the other
other thing said was funny.
She said,
"How can the brokest people
have the richest habit?
(laughs)
How can a person that's so broke
have such a rich habit?"
You know?
And then, and I never really thought
about that like that, and like...
- [Interviewer] 'Cause it
started out as like the
exclusive, like,
the rich man's drug, right?
- The thing you do.
Yeah. But see, it was different then,
like powder, like snorting in and stuff,
after a time, that's going
to take its toll on you too,
but not as fast as smoking rocks, dude.
Smoking rocks, it goes pretty fast,
it goes pretty fast.
And what I think would slow...
'Cause I slowed down from smoking primos.
We started smoking primos,
so it was like a balance steer.
You had the marijuana, you had cocaine,
and you had the marijuana,
but there was a balance.
It wasn't just one way to cocaine,
just...
You're like, the marijuana
keep you leveled a little bit,
and there was a balance.
And now,
how I ended up smoking a pipe is
one day I ran out of weed.
So in the house, I used to keep weed.
Like in the kitchen, in the junk drawer,
I have like roaches and
stuff, like, from...
Little roaches a weed, right?
So I'm looking,
I'm looking for some weed
and I see my mom's crack pipe.
My mom had a crack pipe away.
You know, this is one of
the time she was out of jail
and she had got her apartment
and all that again, you know.
So I was back her not my grandmother
But thing is she stayed right
upstairs from my grandmother
who stayed downstairs,
and she stayed upstairs.
So I wasn't far just in
case she self-destructed,
I could just go back to my grandma, right?
So one day I was looking for the weed
and I seen her crack pipe,
and I was like, "Damn."
But I had never seen her use it though.
I'd never. I knew...
- [Interviewer] Let me ask you a question
as a white boy from Chicago.
Back then, this is the
80's you're talking about?
- Yes
- [Interviewer] How many...
In the South Central,
how many people's moms had
a crack pipe in the drawer?
- Probably just about...
(sighs) a lot.
They're a lot.
Say, out of...
Say out of
the four, five guys that...
My crew, out of four...
Out of my crew, out of
four or five of us...
Say out of five of us,
say, maybe three,
three of us,
maybe four of our moms smoked cocaine,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- was doing it.
- [Interviewer] It was all
over the neighborhood, right?
- It was all over, right.
And it was really bad on women too,
'cause they got used and abused,
and propositioned then, you
know, different types of stuff.
And then I used to think about my mom
was doing this shit, like, "No, no."
But I ended up, you know,
using her stuff, trying it.
'Cause had I seen people doing it.
You know, I never did it
but I used to see like the customer's,
'cause in the spot, we had a room.
Say like, this is the spot we had,
you could buy here and you
can go in that back room
right there and smoke, right?
We would let them go
back there, they'd smoke.
So I seen how they do it.
So
I got it.
I said, "Fuck it, I ain't got no...
I couldn't find no
weed, so let me try it."
So I put a little piece on
there, on the thing and..
that was history.
It was that, that was it.
That was this after that,
'cause that little...
Which I would...
What I would put in the primo,
I had to put a quarter of that on the pipe
and to get that feeling,
and it was just like straight rush (blows)
and like, "Whoa!"
Like it was like, "Oh man,
I've just found my new high,
(indistinct)
(laughs)
Y'all keep spending all that money
and I'm gonna just do this."
But it was bad.
It was bad.
That was the worst thing I
could have ever did, you know.
'Cause it went from there to, like,
I didn't even want no...
to smoke no primos no more,
I just wanted the pipe,
until I went and got me
a pipe and I'm creeping
and then downhill from there,
downhill from there, you know.
And then a lot of guys...
A lot of people found
out that I was really...
I was messing with it.
Rick found out I was
messing with it like that
and he like cut me loose, pretty much,
pretty much cut me loose.
Like, you know, I still can go,
but it wasn't like...
Like, "Man, you're messing
with this stuff, man.
You don't want...
You ain't gonna have no money, you know."
So...
So I just like went all in then.
I'm back,
I'm back on the block robbing people.
(laughs)
I'm back where I started
and now I'm back there again.
But for like...
It was worse then 'cause
some years had went by and...
you hear that it got a little
bit more serious then, so...
- [Interviewer] So are you using today.
- Nah.
I do but I pretty much...
It was like,
right now I use crystal meth.
Crystal meth became the...
Crystal meth is what
stopped me from smoking.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, a lot
of people use it to stop
crack.
- Yeah, it stopped...
Crystal meth Stopped me
from smoking crack cocaine.
It's weird.
And with the crystal meth, I can like...
it's something that...
It ain't, it's not...
It's just different from crack.
I tell everybody now that
smoke crack cocaine, I say,
"You need to start smoking,
messing with crystal."
But the only thing with that,
it's worse on your body.
It's worse on your body
'cause the chemicals...
The chemicals and stuff is
really bad for your body.
It makes your bones weak
and all different type of situations.
And if, I guess if the
chemical that's in this stuff
don't go with the chemicals in your body,
it does different things
to different people.
But because it stopped...
It definitely stopped
me from smoking cocaine
because you don't...
You heard it before?
- [Interviewer] Oh, yeah, many people.
Many people stopped crack
by using crystal meth.
- Using crystal,
which is better because you keep money.
You keep some money in your pocket.
With crack, you're going to
sleep when you have nothing.
You're going to sleep
when you have nothing
- [Interviewer] And then you
stay for two and a half days.
- Yeah, then you sleep
for two and a half days,
and you eat up everything.
When you wake up, you'll
be so starving and hungry,
you want to eat everything.
And it's just bad,
you know.
But like today, now, it's like....
Right now I'm just
trying to figure out what
I'm going to do, like-
- [Interviewer] Do have kids?
- I have a daughter.
I have a daughter,
she's in Minnesota right
now with her mom, you know,
and I haven't talked to her since...
Oh, probably like 20 years.
She's like 32 right now,
you know.
And that was because of the drugs.
That was because of the drugs.
You put everything else on
the back burner for the drugs.
- [Interviewer] There's
so many casualties, right?
It's not just your job and your-
- No, it's
- and your family,
it's everything-
- (indistinct) stuff.
You know, it's like...
Like, I can say right now, I can say,
"I'm hungry, I'm starving," right?
And then a person, say,
you give me five bucks to
go get something to eat.
Soon as I get that five bucks in my hand,
all of a sudden I'm not
that hungry no more,
(laughs)
you know, I'm not that hungry no more.
"Maybe I'll just go buy
me a 50 cent honey bun,
and then that 4.50, I go buy me a hit,"
that's how it works.
And then it gets to the point to...
It's mental.
It's mental 'cause I didn't know at times
where I was on my way...
I was on my way to go get some dope.
But once I got the dope,
knew I was finna get some dope,
All of a sudden I gotta
use the bathroom, I got...
You know,
and that's physical.
That's like mental...
It goes from the mental to the physical.
Like, "I got, now, I gotta take a shit
I gotta use the bathroom real bad."
And I ain't even had the dope yet,
just knowing I'm about to get is...
You understand what I'm saying?
It's crazy.
That's a drug that
I suggest nobody ever-
- [Interviewer] Well,
they're all a curse, right?
Whether it's heroin, or
fentanyl, or crack, or-
- That fentanyl, I did.
Heroin, I tried to snort it.
I tried to snort it one time
and I didn't get it.
And then a lot of people telling me,
"You're lucky you didn't
'cause you would have liked it,
and, you, ain't tell him
where you'll be right now."
And I never tried it again,
I never tried again because
for the simple fact...
I got a brother that's down here right now
that's a heroin addict,
And that's one of my
brothers that I didn't know.
I didn't meet him until my other brother
that I grew up with got killed.
He got killed
and they found him in the alley
right behind our building.
In the alley behind where my
apartment building was at,
right up the alley, they found him.
And that's when I met
my other two brothers
that was in Compton.
And when he got deceased...
No, now just me, which is the youngest,
and the oldest are still living,
the two in between are deceased, you know.
And then the oldest,
he's down here right now,
he's down here.
He's a heroin addict.
I have a auntie that died
from heroin complications,
from years of using heroin.
And I have an uncle that died from...
He OD'd,
did too much at one time
and just died right there like that
of heroin.
- [Interviewer] And
it's still a big factor
in South Central, right?
- Heroin?
- Yeah. No, all these drugs
- All of them, yeah, definitely.
That's how they keep...
(indistinct)
I think that's how you keep us controlled,
keep people controlled,
like population controlled
or something like that.
"We got to control these
people right here."
And that's what I figured,
that's what I see,
that's how I see it, you know, because...
And they're the ones that put
it here in the first place.
Because, I don't know.
As far as I know, Rick
didn't have no boats.
He wasn't going over there
to Peru or
Columbia,
getting that shit and
bringing it back his self,
that stuff was given to him, you know.
It was given to him and he's just...
He was the right man to
give it to, I gotta say,
'cause he was smart.
He was so low key.
He was so low key, man,
you wouldn't even know it.
He was so low key.
But back then, it's the 80s,
especially coming from slums.
Okay, you got these bunch of guys
that never really had nothing, you know,
and you give them some money,
all they want is nice stuff.
They want gold and stuff
that just look, you know,
look like they have something,
which was what they wanted.
They didn't want him to take that money,
they didn't want us to get
that money and buy property,
and buy land and buy
stuff that can, you know,
we could really use in the future.
They wanted us to get some shit
that once you buy it, it turns in...
the value of it turns and there's nothing.
You know, cars, and low riders,
and different stuff like that.
Which in a way...
Which in a way
Rick was doing the same thing with us,
because he would pacify us
with little stuff like that.
He would buy us cars and low
riders and shit, you know,
and different stuff like
that, and guns and shit,
because, like I said, we
were still gang-banging.
We was making money but
we were still gang-banging
so we had all the top-notch weapons
and stuff after a while
like that, and which...
That's when like Uzis and all that stuff
first came around.
We were buying Uzis and
different stuff, so-
- [Interviewer] Because
teenagers need Uzis, right?
- Mm-hmm.
'Cause you just shoot and
(imitates spraying bullets)
just go like that
and shot everybody, but stupid stuff.
It was stupid.
- [Interviewer] All right, Greg
Well, thank you so much for
sharing your interesting story.
- Yeah, man, you're all welcome, thank you
- [Interviewer] Good luck with
wherever you go from here,
man.
- Yeah. Thanks.
- [Interviewer] I hope you get clean.
- Yeah. I'm....
I don't know. I just want a job.
Now, I just want to work.
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever had a real job?
- Yeah, once.
Once I had a job,
this is when I was turned 18.
I worked at burger King.
(interviewer laughs)
I worked at burger King on
Manchester and Halldale,
and I worked there for about six months
and I got fired.
- [Interviewer] That'll
look good on your resume.
- My homeboys found that I worked at there
and they started coming here
and I started cooking them up-
- [Interviewer] If your resume was honest,
(Greg laughs)
you have a very interesting resume.
- Yeah, okay.
- [Interviewer] All right,
man. Thank you so much.
- All right.